[Cheers and applause]
(Dan Sandler): Shetima, I'm a little worried
About this introduction.
I do not think we ... really did not try this at all.
(Chit Haas): [laughing] It will be
Very spontaneous, though we have done it
Repeatedly.
I think it's very spontaneous.
(Dan Sandler): But I am concerned about the introduction itself.
(Chit Haas): Welcome to "What's New in Android".
[clap]
We are delighted to be in the room.
I'm sorry for being the smallest room in Shoreline.
(Dan): That's true.
So there is a place to stand.
If there is a seat next to you, please raise your hand
So that others know that there is a place.
That will help a lot.
I'm Chit Hass from the Android UI Toolkit team.
(Dan): I'm Dan Sandler from the Android System UI team
I'm Roman Guy from Android.
Again, he prepared it again.
again.
[clap]
But not in his team, not again.
(Chit): No, no, no.
[Laughter]
No, it was a successful rebellion.
We will not repeat that problem.
So today we will talk about everything new in Android.
In detail, after taking all the previous things into account
Let's talk about what's new in N.
Oh, hello.
Here it is.
We can also call it what's new in Android.
In fact, you should call it
What's new in Android.
Because we have talked about these things.
We hope that everyone here has a general idea in advance.
And that you have tried to work with them and complained about the mistakes,
You played with new possibilities and features.
So we'll talk about it.
And also we will talk about some things
Which is newer in Developer Freeview 3 and other small things.
Lets start.
The big question is, what does N mean?
I think its meaning - we have moved to Russian this time.
And of course Nyet means not yet, I will not tell you.
But its meaning today is N Preview.
N Preview 3.
So let's talk about - there are several ways
To divide properties,
But we think it would be useful
If we talk about what the user actually sees
And the developers side of it.
Then we will talk about the properties that developers see.
And things related more to the implementation and code that succeeds.
Why not start with Dimo.
[clap]
Yay.
Let's talk about Constraint Layouts.
He has been mentioned in the keyword in the morning.
Steve will talk about it.
And Roman will tell you what is happening.
(Roman): So Constraint Layout is a new interface for Android.
It will be in the Unbundled Library
You'll be able to include them in your app
Without updating the framework.
They are all compatible with Gingerbread.
So you can use it in any application you want.
It is the first interface we designed in conjunction with the same tool.
When we were designing an interface manager for Android,
We also designed this user interface in Android Studio ..
You saw a glimpse of the keyword, but it was hard to see.
We have a system that automatically deduces restrictions.
There are multiple ways in this new system
Which you can create interfaces with.
Here for example, I have a button.
As you see when I move it, my lines of help appear.
It follows the physical design guidelines,
Which will show the appropriate distance for use between different widgets.
It shows the right margin between the widget and the screen.
Now, if I add another button, I can create a constraint between the two buttons.
Now they are straight.
But strong in this new interface editor
Is that we operate the computational solutions behind the android interface
In the Android Studio at 60 frames per second.
When the first button was moved,
You see what happens immediately,
And how the interface resolves all restrictions.
This will give you a much quicker reaction to what is happening.
We can also see this before creating constraint.
When this limitation is made to the screen limit
We'll see you before we leave the mouse button.
We'll give you an overview of what happens if you create that restriction.
I'm sure some of you have RelativeLayout Views
You may have been surprised by what is happening
When we send an extra widget.
Everything goes to another end of the screen.
This will not be repeated.
So additional restrictions can be created quickly
And add the two buttons below.
You can also use AutoConnect.
If you turn it on when I put a new button on the screen,
When you see help lines, for example, in the center of the screen,
If you put my buttons here,
The system will create restrictions automatically.
So I do not have to do it myself.
But you can print, change the entries afterwards.
You can resize easily,
So you can take all the space or leave it all.
We also have a percentile move.
Here, the button was in the middle.
But you can say I want him, for example
25% from the top of the screen.
You will adjust to the size of your screen.
There are other features that we will try on Friday at 9 am.
For example, we have a balanced dimension,
You can always make widgets
1: 1 with a balanced dimension to 16: 9 or any dimensions you want.
In the end, the thing you've seen a glimpse of in the keyword.
If you put several widgets on the screen,
To move it as a text field from the top, I will click TextView from the label.
Carefully describe them to the user interface.
I will destroy all restrictions.
Now if you click on this Field Label icon,
You'll know what I want to do.
My interface will simply work.
You will not be locked.
You can add the restrictions again.
You can change behavior again.
I can add another widget.
And the work of automatic inference again,
You have the right to work
On the appropriate user interface, and create them more quickly.
[clap]
Thanks Roman.
And also...
Sorry, something extra.
This is a small overview.
Call it Alpha 1.
It's still a rough draft.
So upload Android 2.2 Preview.
Play it.
They gave us complaints about mistakes.
I will check the complaints collector myself.
I will ask engineers
To correct most of those mistakes.
We have more on the way.
We are still working on that.
This does not represent the final version in any way
UI and UI editor.
One last question,
how much is it?
[Laughter]
100 KB.
Is this good?
[Laughter]
(Dan): But you also, Chit?
4 million dollars.
[Laughter]
Well if they play it.
And give us feedback.
To get back to the Slids.
But that was a great demo.
But I want to see the salads again.
(Dan): Good luck coloring that.
Excellent.
Multiple windows, are the most visible developments in N.
It is the possibility of multiple activities on the screen at one time.
There are two kinds of that you may see.
Someone is splitting the screen which is side by side.
Or if you work horizontally head to tail.
If we go to Recents, we can see the screen record here,
We have the ability to traction of Recents
To half the screen.
And the work that you are doing
Be in the other half of the screen.
You can click on someone to be your second activity.
When you drag things, you'll notice that Window Manager
Simply color the background until you leave the button.
And then you have a complete change of order.
One of the things that makes it work on its own in your application
Is the magic of Android Layouts.
We know how to change the hierarchy.
We know how to adjust the interface to suit new sizes
And the properties of screen formats.
Window Manager will run from above
So when you go to the new size and strength
With side-by-side interface, your app will work simply.
So prefer and test it.
Make sure it works the way you want
Either side-by-side or split screen mode.
Use the API if you need it.
You have the option to do so.
It's automatically selected for you by default.
But you can say that you do not want
Be a scalable activity.
There are some properties that you can set for default and minimum scaling.
You can listen to APIs
To know when the system will become in the multi-window mode
Or you are in that way now.
Finally, if you are in multiple window mode
You want to start a new activity to the first,
You can request to be parallel to the first.
Go and check it out.
Also check the image in the image mode.
This is the other half of the multi-window mode
Where you can on Android TV
To operate an activity consisting of an image within an image.
For example, playing a full video
With another activity
Users can choose to watch at the same time,
With the first video working in the foreground.
For all these properties and more,
Please go to the multiple windows lesson today at 4pm.
There are little photo activities inside the picture,
Basically like the one we saw in the multi-window mode
To see when that will happen
And what can you do after him?
There is a new drag and drop property.
We've had drag and drop in the podium
Since Gingerbread at least.
We have added to that property now.
Because you are now in a multiplicity mode.
Would not it be nice to pull from one activity to another?
Which was not allowed by the previous drag and drop method
Because we did not need to.
But now we want to withdraw material
To and from activities.
So we added a little API
And capabilities that allow you to do so.
See some of the APIs here.
Many of which are about permissions.
Probably because that activity
He did not want you to copy from the password domain
To your activity.
Or maybe no cat video
To fall on your activity.
So there is little giving and taking
To allow for correct permissions.
There are also ways to start commands,
Or to cancel orders on their way,
To update Drag Shadow, which has an inappropriate contact name.
This is just the formation of thumbnails
For the piece of material being pulled.
You can update it for anything you want.
You can also update it repeatedly
If you want to revive shadow formation.
(Dan): Yes.
(Chit): If that's your intention.
So we can see a quick record of the screen.
You can see it working here.
Well, to see.
These are some of our internal democracies.
They will be published as an article and a demo
You can run it externally.
It shows the initial interaction
To drag an article that does not have permissions
In spite of giving them permissions
And thus have the ability to draw between applications.
Let us move forward.
So we have notifications.
(Dan): Well, then you all saw us
We do this lecture in advance, I hope so.
And you know that this is the part
Where he stole the talk for a quarter of an hour,
To talk about all the new things in brilliant alerts.
But this is not true this time because they gave me my own talk.
So go back to the 9 am.
We will be deeply involved in everything that is new and exciting
In Android and Android 2.0 notifications
Which you have seen in the keynote address.
I will ...
(Chit): Give me the cursor right away.
No, I have not finished yet.
wait.
[Laughter]
I just want to mention some of the things I want you to pay attention to,
Or maybe to attract you to learn more
Or read about them in designer documents.
First we have new interfaces for the first time,
The fact since Honeycomb.
With we had told the material a bit
Since a few updates ago.
Some of the new interfaces to move things a bit,
And create new versions of the application
Which sent the alerts.
So you will always know
He who puts things in your faces.
We also have bundled notifications,
Which we designed mainly for Android ware.
And finally became possible on mobile and Tab,
The possibility of collecting such notifications.
We also have a direct response,
A property touch the answer button, and then write directly into the shadow.
This is also one of the things that have been in Android ware for some time now.
You can talk to your watch
And make them send a message.
Now you can do the same even from the locked screen,
If the user has allowed it.
Since I'm here and talking about UI-related things,
I would like to talk to you about quick settings.
We finally did what the user asked us to do
A long time ago,
Is to make them changeable.
We now allow you to choose Add or Cancel
Any of the quick settings you want.
We have actually what is better and is called the most rapid settings.
I think I invented that name now.
The fastest setting is the five-point list,
Any of the five most frequently used settings
Which appear at the top of the list of alerts
At any time you look at it.
If you move them to get the five favorite
You'll be able to reach them in one touch,
Any time you look at your notices.
[clap]
But see.
there is more.
So the designers who follow us at home,
Learn from the end profile that you can create
Your Quick Settings Now
Which any Android N user can carry.
So, take a look at the API documentation
About TileService.
This will create a complete life cycle around the Quick Configuration Panels
Which allows you to know when the user added the tile to the list,
When the tiles are seen.
If you want to live updates, you can do that.
And then most important of course
What to do when the user clicks on the tile.
When you call getQsTile you will get a handle
For the purpose of the tile, which bear all cases
It allows you to do things like changing the icon,
Change the address, enter and exit the event status,
Which allows you to reduce or decrease the light
Whether that resource was available.
After all these changes have been made,
Please do not forget to send the updateTile.
So this is perfect for your settings.
That's a quick property to apply
You know that the user wants to access it from their closed screen.
If you are busy building your smart home,
The first thing you want to do is create a quick button
From your phone so you can turn it on
And make it play your own music when you enter your home.
This is exactly what quick settings do.
The last thing you have to do is etc etc etc ...
Things on the menu
To make sure you have all the correct permissions
To identify the user interface as a tile in quick settings
Know what to do with them.
Let's talk about blocking the screen a bit.
This is really a property to allow access
Which we offer within N to increase and replace font size.
Font size has always been subject to change
In Android for a long time.
You know, developers, if you specify the characters in ASPI
Which doubles the font size selected by the user
So the user can say that he needs a little more help,
Or he wants to see a little more words on the screen.
But as you also know, stylists
That ASPI is very limited, right?
We do not change models by font size.
You can encapsulate content to resolve these shapes.
But there are certain parts of the system
Such as notifications,
Which did not adapt
Well done.
Because the geometry size
Did not change to acclimate to the added words.
Now we have a screen size property in Android N.
Go to the screen settings, and click on them.
The point per inch will change on the device at run time.
It becomes a new way to change all the user interface on the device
New density is not just words.
So you can zoom in or out
So you can get the most benefits from that small screen.
You can use 0.85 to 1 or 1/2.
I do not have to explain this now.
But please avoid pixels in your designs.
Because this will change the density on your computer,
This will double if you use non-device pixels
In your designs and other calculations.
The other thing you have to do,
I will show you some little video to illustrate it,
Is to make sure your app works
Very well in sw320dp.
I know,
I know we all carry those big paintings
Which we call phones.
There are very small screens too.
But if the user does not have a sudden density
So that the screen is actually sw320dp,
Your app will need to handle it smoothly.
We have a video here to show you what is happening right away.
This is a direct volume change.
Enter the screen size,
Move the button larger or smaller.
And believes that everything will change in size,
Not only words, but the navigation bar and status bar,
And all those important things.
In fact, I have an explanation here.
This is the default size appearance.
If you change the font size only, some things will grow bigger,
But other things will not be affected.
Of course, the screen size will change everything.
You can finally make every part of the user interface
Large sized decent view
Or small enough to store all this information on the screen.
Let's talk about localities.
(Chit): Yeah, let's do it.
Well thank Dan.
Multiple sweeteners.
[clap]
no no no.
I will not do it yet.
[Laughter]
You know what wonderful,
Is to see the geometry and shape of the shed
According to empty seats in the hall.
It's very hot there, is not it?
(Dan): That's one of the reasons why you watch a 360 broadcast.
(Chit): Yes.
But it is not hot at home for live broadcast.
Well for those who come home,
Let us talk about the multiple mullahs.
But demand was heavy in several editions.
We discovered that outside our country
People speak different languages.
[Laughter]
That's true.
I was told that.
People like you.
For these people, it is very difficult to deal with the user interface.
Because sometimes you may want some content or some applications
To speak to you using one of these languages,
Or that there is a different regression from the system assumptions
When it does not have the appropriate resources,
Whatever.
There are many accidents
Where you already want to adjust several languages ​​and localities to work with.
Now we can do it.
Not only can you adjust all these languages,
But their order according to
What you want to do on your device.
You can also add some new languages ​​and styles
Which we have added.
We have a record of the screen here
Let's see how to choose it.
Go to languages,
I had only one selected,
I do not know why.
Let's go and choose the duet.
Which are German, not Dutch,
For your information only.
I will choose the style of Liechtenstein,
Because I think it's funny.
And then register it and put it first.
Suddenly I can not read my user interface.
Because it has become the basic language
Of the whole system.
These are multiple localities, I hope you use them.
Let's talk about the status of the goat.
We have had a parachute in Marshmallow.
So I'll reconsider it a bit.
A chart of health workers has been stolen from the system,
So I think it's easy to understand.
I will put the chart there.
You will understand directly what the status of the funeral.
It is quite clear as I think.
But I will clarify some things
And alert you to the important in it.
First, it begins to work when the screen is locked,
The device is stationary, works on its battery,
It will work for a short time.
It then begins to sleep
Here is the bottom where you see that green part
Here at the bottom.
And then there are these windows for maintenance
Which appears now and suddenly
Activities can operate on the system,
And to carry out its normal tasks during those windows.
And then we have these periods growing exponentially
Between those windows.
They talk over time.
At the same time we have these conditions of the goat,
Where activities do not do much.
No network connection.
There are deferred jobs and jobs.
There is no WakeLocks.
All good.
This allows for longer battery life.
All this is easy to understand.
But let's go inside and talk about N.
So in N we have all these things.
But also we have this situation, put the lighter lighter extra
Which does not require you to be consistent.
So also the phone can
Be in someone's pocket for a very long time
Without being used.
Would not be nice in that case that the activities do not eat
Of battery power then?
He will pay attention to this unstable situation.
And wait for some time,
Then the status of the goat begins.
Then comes maintenance windows.
You have less activity,
Not like Marshmallow but the same idea here.
All this is easy to understand again.
We will note on the graph that you have similar colors
For some materials there.
Which means that they are put together together.
In the end, we have a similar bar code.
All of this is understandable.
[Laughter]
Let us note that the capabilities of N,
Putting light snakes that you talked about,
It is actually totals of function mainly.
We have all the things from N when the device is stationary,
In addition to this light situation all the time.
If we really want to understand it,
We will put the data charges together,
It will become this way.
[Laughter]
I will say as I said earlier, this is clear.
[clap]
Some people thought it would use more words.
We explain that quickly.
In Marshmallow you have the device.
Screen is locked.
It works on battery.
The place is fixed.
At that time you can not easily use the network.
Your activities and stimuli have been delayed and there is no WakeLocks.
The service will be restricted in light mode N,
In all of the above.
But it should not be fixed.
It can be moving in your pocket or wherever it is.
Then you have fewer restrictions.
Because there is a spasm of activities in the background
Which are still available at the time.
Please go to modern battery and memory optimizations
Today at 5 pm to learn more about this topic
As well as things related to system health.
When I talk about the health aspects of the system,
Let's talk about the Svelte project.
This project has been underway for a number of issues
To see everything going on in the system
Of things that make the battery lose its capacity faster,
And then see what we can say to the conciliators to correct in the application
And to work on that requirement, as well as what we can do on the platform.
So we did.
In N you can bid farewell to the following orders.
I'm sure we'll miss them so much.
But they had to be uprooted.
There are those cases that we have noticed,
While the research team is working
That something might happen
Such as communication order,
A message appears,
All activities are covered.
Because they wanted to know when the Wi-Fi network had changed.
For example, if you walk in your office building,
Moving from router to router,
All such activities,
What will they do?
nothing.
Then they will go back to sleep.
At the same time the system has been shocked.
Because they all woke up,
They will not be able to remember all of them at the same time.
We will get rid of the ancients to allow the newcomers,
Then we get into this shocking situation.
Similarly in new videos and photos.
The user taped a picture,
An expense report decides that it wants to know the new image.
Because it was probably a sign of a bill.
The application will be added to 50 of his friends,
It will be noticed that the picture is not important to him
For it is for one of the cats that she has met.
The application will then return to sleep.
This is also shocking to the system.
Why not underestimate those things and increase battery life
And the age of the device to be more useful to the user
Simply delete all those messages?
In fact, the new method is to use JobScheduler,
Which we have been talking about for several years now.
There is a special programming interface new applications you should pay attention to,
Which allows you to ask when the content changes.
Not directly, because the problem was so
In the old method.
But with time, when the scheduled work is done,
You will be able to find out if there is any new content that interests you.
Again, go to the Talk Improvement Battery and Memory
To learn more about these things.
(Dan): And then that application will call you back
To take pictures of the cat as you like.
Yes Yes,
It turned out that the bell on the cat was important to determine the expenses.
Yes, good point, thank you.
Well, Data Saver has now become possible for the user
That says to the device or system
It wants to restrict the size of the data
Which is used by applications.
Here, for example, where I live,
I do not care much about Wi-Fi,
Because I have an unlimited data subscription.
It's not a big problem.
But this is not true for the world.
People may pay very high overpriced
For network subscriptions,
Or may be too slow.
So everyone may not want to use the limited data they own.
Or perhaps have restrictions.
Here we give them the ability to really reduce it,
Not just say that we use less data,
But to tell applications whether the data is available to them, restricted, or completely prohibited.
There's a place to go in your system settings now
You can choose this for each application.
In terms of designers, you should pay attention to this.
Because you may be banned at any time.
There are ways in your system
To see if this happens,
In order to search for a communication service,
And see if you are a - on a restricted network
Or (b) whether access in the background is available or restricted at that time.
(Roman): Direct Boot is one of my favorite features in Android N.
If you have a PIN code on your device,
And you have encrypted the device,
If the device is restarted for some reason, to upload an update,
Or automatic updates are effective,
Or to restart amnesty,
You will notice that your phone is stuck on the PIN code screen,
It is waiting for you to enter your password.
You may lose messages, e-mail or even calls at the time.
Now, what the system does
Is that it will work until the lock screen
Before asking for a PIN code.
And until the password is entered
Some apps will work.
You can register your app
In order to be able to operate in this mode from Direct Boot,
Which means that even from that closed screen
You can do some tasks,
Such as receiving calls or messages.
If you want to know more about this,
And find out what you can do in your app
To work in that situation, I beg you to come to talk
Thursday at 9 am.
Will be within the modern Android protection.
Another feature has been asked a lot,
Are access to specific directories
On external memory.
If your app wants to look at images,
Music, video, or anything else
In the external memory of the user,
Until now you should have requested access to the entire memory.
That was a somewhat scary permit
For users who wanted to download the app
From the Play Store.
Now, however, as we see on the picture,
Your app can select the request
For one place or directory in memory, such as photos or music only.
And combined with the new permissions system in N,
It becomes very clear to the user
What is the work of the application,
And what the app can access.
(Chit): Androde to work.
I advise you to go to their talk.
There are a lot of events there.
I just want to mention some properties
Especially in Android to work in this version.
So go to the talk on Thursday at 2:00 am Your Apps at Work.
Please listen to him,
But at the same time if you have profiles installed to work on your phone,
There is a new feature called Work Mode.
Which is in fact to abolish the working status of work.
So they are with a question mark
In front of the ferry
Non-working mode!
You can go to Quick Settings
And stop its work easily.
You will see, I do not know if you see it on the screen,
The Work Profile application has been shut down.
If you click on one of these,
You'll get a small message telling you no no no,
This does not work now.
So it's easy to turn on and off this job.
You can spend the weekend
Without seeing the e-mail if you like.
There is also something called the Work Challenge.
Which we hope will be removed from some ugly endorsements
Carried out by some companies.
They will need the more restricted password
And what follows on the screen.
They will no longer need to do that.
They can provide a password
Use only when a Work Profile application is running.
We'll see a small screen record about it.
If you want to apply a Work Profile,
Your password will be confirmed here,
The application starts.
Now if you enter and run another application,
Will enter it directly,
Because you have already entered your password
To the entire system.
(Roman): But now the real reason
For our presence here, the characteristics of designers.
The largest one has been mentioned in the keyword.
They are run-time changes.
Now we have a much faster translator,
Which means that when your app is loaded,
Will not be pre-assembled like what was in Lollipop and Marshmallow.
But will work first in the development of translation.
And when JIT sees the code snippet in your app
That are running frequently, or that may benefit from higher performance,
You will start working and assembling things in just the right time.
When your device is idle,
We will collect some information collected by JIT
To assemble part of the application in advance in the capacity of time.
We are actually doing three operations,
Compiler, and JIT assembling in advance in the capacity of time.
Ask us for a few years.
We have tried these three in the past.
Now we are all doing them at the same time.
I sincerely advise you to come and talk on Friday
1 pm from ART, The Evolution of ART.
They will give you much more information on how this works.
We have new libraries from Runtime Libraries.
One of their chiefs is ICU4J, which is now part of the framework.
The ICU library is useful for globalization,
And the web civilization of your application.
It's a fairly large library.
It is now part of the framework
In the name of a different package so as not to conflict with other package names.
And is now reliable in the framework of action.
You can reduce the size of your APK.
We also added some java.util bouquets
So there is java.util.function
Which contain classes and APIs
Useful for programming practical method such as Predicates.
We also have a new Streaming API
Very useful when we combine them with the characteristics of the new language.
If you want to use one of the new language properties in Java 8,
You have to change some of the gradlebuildfile files
To switch to the new Jack compiler.
You also have to say that you want binary compatibility and my resources
With version 1.8 of the programming language.
After doing so you have access to Lambdas properties.
The Lambdas were implemented using unknowns in your ranks,
In rapid speech,
Which means they are compatible with the systems to Gingerbread.
You have some examples of what Lambdas is.
If you do not know what they are, or have never used,
There are many documents and articles on the net.
Go and take a look.
Will make your life much better,
Especially if you are using RxJava
Or just an Android framework for the user interface.
Lambdas makes anything that needs a lot more work easier.
But be careful because these things
Create many anonymous rows.
It is actually a little more expensive compared to what is apparent.
But that will not affect most applications.
Default and Static Interface
They are very useful properties, unfortunately
Not compatible with legacy systems.
If you have an existing interface,
You can now add new methods and pull out our default settings,
Much like you can do in abstract rows.
This is very important for moving your APS forward without breaking
Everything or break your customers.
You can also use it to create a famous converter style
Which you may have seen with a lot of listeners.
If your listener has several ways to reconnect,
There is usually a transformer row
Comes to his side and has an empty execution
For all these methods,
If you want to implement only one of these methods,
You do not have to advertise them completely.
This is now very easy with default methods.
You can use static methods on the interfaces.
Repeat the blogging, I'm sure many of you
All these frames are used for business
With lots of blogging, but you like this property.
Which unfortunately do not correspond to the old systems.
But that means that now, with one pedigree,
As in the @Exportable example at the bottom,
It can be written several times on the same type.
For example, we have a row here
We want to appreciate its publication in episodes on different formats.
We can reuse the code instead of using the arrays
Of the values ​​in the code.
The audio team, or the media team, is working very hard
In older versions of Android to reduce audio latency.
Much of this work has already been done at local levels of the system.
In the end they worked to reduce the ambient noise in the upper layers.
You can predict, depending on your device, of course,
Latency is worth 40 to 70 milliseconds when playing sound.
Very easy to activate.
You can see an example here on the screen.
When you create sound features for your media player
You can set it to low latency.
We will give you access to this property.
There are also some APIs
You can use it to optimize playback.
You can create numbers for underruns
Which occur when running the media.
You can also resize dynamically
For your ideas to carry out the work in case there are many underruns.
If you want to learn more about it,
Especially if you want to know
How to use APIs to increase latency more,
You can go to talk on Thursday at 3pm.
Renderscript is a set of improvements.
Is now in the consolidated resource file.
You can have many nuclei that can not communicate with each other.
This makes it easier to create complex software.
We also have decreasing nuclei.
You can make a Map Reduce type from the API.
For example, if you want to computerize a graph,
You can do this with a decreasing nucleus.
You have access to several photos.
We added Allocation.getByteBuffer,
And it will help you to minimize
Of the number of allocations that occur when the Renderscript kernel is running.
In the end, if you're working with a lot of data,
We have support for floating-point numbers from 16-bit,
Which helps you reduce your data size by half.
If accuracy works for you,
You should definitely consider it.
And to the graphics people, OpenGL ES 3.2
It is the newest version of OpenGL ES
Which we send with Android N,
It is practically OpenGL ES 3.1 plus something
Named Android accessories package.
The Android Extensions package was a set of OpenGL extensions
So that if the package is on the machine itself
You are guaranteed access to all of those accessories.
It has greatly facilitated the lives of OpenGL designers.
So it was wrapped with the needs of OpenGL ES 3.2 itself except one NEN plug-in
Which you see on the slide.
Some glimpses contain advanced mixing equations.
So the device will handle all things mixing modes
That you find in Photoshop or their image editing program.
You do not have to write the glosses anymore,
Because it is part of OpenGL.
You can use mosaics coverings and engineering solutions.
These are very useful for creating runtime geometry.
So usually you can do is create a fairly simple network,
The closer you get to the thing,
You can dynamically increase triangles
To show it smoother on the screen
Without the use of large memory or greater performance
When you do not need those triangles.
There is a new compressed format for installation
Called ASTC in addition to some other properties
Which you will love very much if you use OpenGL ES.
Vulkan has also mentioned in the keyword,
Here are some additional details.
There will be a talk of his own
Today at 6 pm.
The Vulkan is a GUI-level API for graphics.
Its level is lower than OpenGL.
Somehow, you actually become the driver.
You can generate commands for the GPU
From a variety of topics,
Which will help improve the efficiency of your application.
There is not as much overhead in the same driver.
You can make more call charges.
You can fill the screen with more material.
You can also group shadings in advance without connecting to the intranet,
This is very useful in investigations
Or to make heavy improvements,
Because program drivers on the device are trying to find a balance between optimizing shadings
Not spending too much time to assemble them.
It is also a multi-device API.
The Vulkan also appears in Android N,
Is Vulkan itself which you will find in Windows and Linux.
Program operators are sold from today.
So you can write your code on my desktop,
And then run it on your phone.
It's also a bit harder than OpenGL ES.
You must manage memory and sync by selecting.
So we are expected to see great natamia in Vulkan equipment.
Engines such as Unity and Unreal Engine
Works to support Vulkan or have support for it.
Your position will be good if you are using one of these engines.
Your apps will be better than no price.
(Chit): There have been improvements
For adb in terms of efficiency and performance.
We made it more perfect in character, more like the structure.
For example, you can get something larger than something like LS.
You can take results from what happens in adb
And pass them to other operations on the host.
You can do things more perfect in its properties.
There are also significant improvements to performance
Especially for payment and withdrawal
By a very complex algorithm
The increase in size of the beaver is called.
[Laughter]
This is how we work here in Google.
So...
(Dan): Come on ...
(Chit): If you know adb, you will not have a choice.
But you will enjoy it.
(Roman): Get the status of the checkout process
And the possibility of passing standard data
The remote machine can be very useful to have automatic tests, for example.
You can turn on many automatic things on your device
And get the correct results.
Everything we changed in NDK,
Is that we have brought Clang to 3.8 and GCC to 4.9.
But with the GCC,
This will be the latest version of the GCC
Which works with NDK.
If you are not using GCC,
This is the time to test your application NDK with Clang.
It is time to move forward.
We made arm7 architecture the default.
You can forget the old architecture.
It will be your logo now
To benefit from improvements
Which take into account today's hardware requirements.
(Chit): VR, we've heard a little about him
In the keyword.
And you have a chance to hear more about him
During the rest of this week.
I wanted to talk about the huge server space of the API
Which you should pay attention to.
First you need to know the characteristics of the device.
The devices are a bit limited in capacity
Owned as we heard in the keyword.
Then, pay attention to this API.
I will say that you want other information,
Please go to your talk.
As we have seen there are many conversations.
Another Mary was asked there were about 18 conversations on VR.
Choose whatever you want.
I think that the biggest of them,
Where they will talk about technical details,
It is tomorrow morning at about nine o'clock.
But make sure the table.
You will know if you are using the VR statement.
It is a ...
(Dan) Sorry, did you say VR?
(CHIT): VR.
He noted that there were four quotations.
Not just two.
It's four.
(Dan): Did you say four?
Okay.
(Chit): In each hand.
(Roman): I will just add that if you do not write
Experience a VR, a game, or a virtual museum,
Etc., this API will not benefit you.
Do not run it in your app just because you think it might speed up its work.
It's not for you.
It is for VR virtual reality experts only.
(Chit): Well!
not for you.
(Roman): Not you.
[Laughter]
(Chit): Well, the Suppot Library support library is new in N.
But I wanted to speak quickly and concisely
For some things that were in some previous versions.
In Release 23.2 we had some things
Which people were waiting for.
There are possibilities of night mode.
Is the ability of your application to move quickly between the light and dark appearance.
Bottom Sheets for material design
Also Vector / Drawable and AnimatedVectorDrawable,
People have asked all these since we issued the basic features on Lollipop
As if we did not know.
It proved very difficult to implement
For some reason the way resources are handled,
In addition to the drawings,
And make it compatible with previous systems.
It took time.
But finally became possible.
It is compatible with several previous versions.
They are tempted to discover them and use them.
And start selling smaller APKs.
Because tankers are usually much smaller than the pictures
Such as PNGs and JPEGs.
RecyclerView and AutoMeasure, and also Wrap Content Wrap Contents,
They have asked a lot for a while.
This is in that version.
Then at 23.1 we modified the RecyclerView API
To allow for more performance, and rich-textured animations.
Check out these too.
(Roman): As the talk about VectorDrawable,
There will be a talk by Colt I do not remember when.
It is about reducing the size of images and what can be done
To reduce your APKs size.
It will talk about VectorDrawables,
But also what you can do with PNGS,
And JPEGs and WebPs to make your applications smaller
But with the same beautiful appearance.
(Chit): Yeah, right.
Support Library,
I also wanted to talk about what I want to call the future.
There are some interesting events that designers will be eagerly interested in.
But we also have a talk called What's New in the Support Library.
In order not to spoil the surprise,
I will tell you to attend the talk today at four o'clock
To learn more about what will happen in future releases
In the Support Library.
I want to talk quickly about these things,
Because I love them.
This is a detail of implementation.
No one will know from outside.
But VectorDrawable performance may improve a lot
In the N Preview version,
Because we worked on performance improvements
In both sides of the load and the firstDraw side.
We will create the bitmap,
And we paint it there.
It took us a long time to chart that path.
We have speeded it up.
We also quickly did his comment.
If you have a very complicated path,
It turns out that the expression of that string at the Java level,
It was very intense time.
We have important legislation there.
This is a bigger reason to start using VectorDrawables.
And also FloatProperty and IntProperty.
It is my favorite feature because I have run on my own.
This really is ...
(Roman): Was that the only code you wrote in N?
(Chit): That's possible.
(Roman): I'm sure of that.
(Chit): No, no.
In fact, I wrote much more code,
I also reviewed them.
There were problems,
My review was canceled.
[Laughter]
Not only did I not write the code much
In FloatProperty / IntProperty,
But have written for more than two years.
But it was a hidden API.
But we discovered that people can not reach
To the capabilities that allow the use of primitives
With proprietary material until the API is detected as generic.
These are all.
I beg you to use it.
Especially for the movers that allow you
In a more direct way to change settings
Without the usual mechanism,
Such as what we use drives and dive into JNI and support.
This will add a little improvement in performance.
What do we have after that?
Android Instant Apps Android Instant Apps
Which we have seen in the keyword this morning.
And you see us go to the Sandbox area and discover the demons.
They also brought the conversation tomorrow morning
What's New in Android Play for Developers
They will have more details about it.
Most importantly, go and get the release.
If you do not own it yet,
Developer Preview 3 will now be available there.
I do not know the times of ahaadeeth
When they are on interwebs networks.
But there must be,
So they wanted to go there.
These are some useful sites in case you do not know d.android.com
here they are.
Get the Preview,
Download the SDK.
More importantly, please send complaints,
And very quickly.
We are trying to end this release.
is there anything else?
(Roman): Can we take ...
I just want to talk a bit about the Constraint model,
Because I care about him a lot.
There is also Code Lab you can go to
If you want to play it now.
Other than that, we can take some questions.
It would be strange in this lounge, but ...
(Dan): Do not I think I have a microphone?
(Chit): I do not manage how we can take questions here.
(Roman) spoke very loudly.
(Cheet): Do you know?
I will tell the two thousand people who have questions
They will not be able to ask,
We will have office times at the end of each day.
There are office times called Android N desk times.
There will be plenty of people on platforms.
People who worked on N,
They turned out to be the same people who worked on all other versions.
And let your questions be brought there.
There are office times for different teams for multiple windows and so on.
Make sure they are in the table.
So ask your questions.
I think we will skip the questions.
Roman: Well.
(Chit): It's rather strange there.
So we do not end the conversation,
We will say thank you.
(Roman): Thank you.
[clap]
[Music]